persecución y asedio policial denuncia
rolando álvarez obispo nicaragüense
inició una huelga de hambre que asegura
no detendrá hasta que el gobierno y la
policía se comprometan a respetar su
integridad y la de su familia
solo se desplaza por las calles de
nicaragua y ve como las patrullas van y
vienen en verdad estamos viviendo una
situación de terror de tal manera que
aquí no sólo religioso sacerdote sino
también muchos nicaragüenses
álvarez fue uno de los intermediarios en
los fallidos diálogos entre el gobierno
y la oposición en 2018 año en que exigió
justicia por más de 350 personas
fallecidas luego de las protestas contra
un gobierno que ya atraviesa su quinto
mandato y que ha sido fuertemente
criticado por violar los derechos
humanos ahora la policía se mantiene a
las afueras de la iglesia donde el
sacerdote realiza la huelga de hambre
lo que pasa es que
el gobierno siempre ha pretendido una
iglesia muda no quiere que hablemos no
quiere que anunciamos la esperanza al
pueblo ni denunciamos la injusticia
mientras tanto por órdenes del ente
regulador de telecomunicaciones de
nicaragua desde este viernes por la
noche el canal católico dirigido por el
obispo ya no realizará más transmisiones
a través de la plataforma del operador
de cable
informamos a nuestros usuarios de
televisión por suscripción que por
indicaciones de telcor ente regulador el
canal 51 canal católico está siendo
eliminado de la grilla de programación
del servicio por su parte la
arquidiócesis de managua viene alertando
de hostigamiento del gobierno a
religiosos por supuesta traición a la
patria